okay hello everyone we are Thomas
Patrick and Eric garlic and we are
working at Allegro and we're going to
talk about learning to rank alright so
first few words about our company so
Allegro is the biggest e-commerce site
in our region and that I go to
destination when it comes to online
shopping in Poland all right and also
few words about ranking before we talk
about learning to rank so basically
ranking is the key part of any search
engine and that's definitely a key part
of Allegro and back in the day is
ranking function needs to be hunt
crafted but now with the event of of
machine learning we want to have good
algorithms that will provide
personalized and more accurate search
results so all of those machine learning
algorithms that work for ranking have a
common term and that's learning to rank
yeah so to summarize learning to rank is
a machine learning subfield in which we
aim to train a model that will order a
document for for a query and being a
supervised learning approach we need
some crunch sugar labels and collecting
them through through some human judgment
from human experts is quite expensive
and time-consuming so in practice we
usually rely on an implicit feedback so
feedback provided by feedback provided
by users through the behavior through
through what they do on the on the NSL
change so this is how we formulate
learning to rank in e-commerce setting
we treat offers as documents we collect
a they're the vector representation we
convert a user in query to to the
context and uh and combine it with some
true labels about whether particular
offer was was interesting for for user
and before we dive deep into how to
solve such a task let's think about the
metric that we are going used to use to
evaluate ourselves and a typical one for
ranking task is end ECG
which stands for normalize discounted
cumulative gain and so on the right you
see a curve for a single for single
value of them of a game of a discounted
gain of of of an relevant document
presented at ed put at a specific
position so we can see the curve is
really steep and it puts much emphasis
on the top few positions and he in the
list and we'll talk about it maybe a
moment later why why is that and you sum
over all the relevant documents in the
list and normalize it by dividing it
through an ideal DCG so the one that
would be perfect for given search result
list so the range of dimetric is between
zero and one all right now we're going
to talk about different learning to rank
methods we divide them in few groups and
those groups are point wise pair wise
and leastwise approaches so first we're
going to talk about the point wise
approach here basically we have some
features that describe a given document
maybe some some additional context and
what we do is we basically train a
classifier to classify for clicks or for
some other actions that are of our
interest and that police fire might be
you know as simple as a logistic
regression trained trained with with
cross-entropy so that approach obviously
works but it doesn't take into account
the context that the document is within
so basically is just a document in
isolation doesn't look at other
documents that go here are the same
listing and that might be actually a
valuable information we all think is
that we are not optimizing for NDC G
which is like our metric of interest we
are just optimizing our classifier but
it has been shown that perfect
classification leads to perfect ranking
or the approach that does the pairwise
one we are going to talk about that by
example of Ryan
that in this model we train a neural
network to express the scoring function
but that's not the most important part
we can use any any function the most
important part is how we optimize is how
we define our optimization procedure so
in this case we have some documents
let's call them UI and UJ and what we
are interested in is the probability
that the user would prefer one document
of over the other and that's what we try
to optimize and we do that as usual
we've we've cross entropy in the end we
can take advantage of the fact that we
are comparing documents in pairs and not
in isolation and that's provides and
that provides but the results okay so
the last approach would be a list wise
one and here we want to build some kind
of intuition about what's really the key
point in an analysis wise approach not
going into the details of specific
implementations so we can see two two
searches a list with two relevant
documents on each marked with those blue
lines and you can see that the the left
one is more pairwise errors and right
one although it has much better and the
CGT value so you can see that this is a
kind of a good example of where those
approaches would differ in terms of what
should be what should be optimized and
for forgiving situation so with those
arrows on the right we show the gradient
that would be formed by pairwise those
would be those black ones algorithm and
the least wise one that would try to
optimize and DCG those would be this red
arrows so you can see that they try to
move did not not the same not the same
documents at first so the stronger their
strength of the gradient is is different
here so we try to optimize the whole
result list at once and we would like to
optimize our final metric of course this
will be the best however it's hard to to
optimize and ECG directly using
gradient-based method because it's
derivative is not defined everywhere or
zero so those approaches try to avoid
this issue and in some ways for example
lambda rank is using its assigning a
weight do a pairwise pairwise close for
every pair that is weighted by a
difference by change of end ECG given
those pair of documents would be swapped
so it's it's yeah this kind of brings
the optimization of of and ECG with with
purse all right now now having some
knowledge about those different
approaches we're going to talk about how
we have actually implemented our
production system how we implemented
learning to rank the right company so
before we could train any model we
needed to collect our data set obviously
and what was of our interest was was the
context in which someone was looking for
something obviously offer features and
the list of actions so when we want to
talk to my default click that would be
click for transaction that would be a
transaction and well it was not a
trivial task having our very huge
platform and diverse data sources but
then we we managed to create such a data
set and that included offer features
that included some custom of aggregates
that we have obviously some user
features search events lots of front end
event and wherever whenever it was
possible we wanted to use aggregated
data sources and that's for a reason
that it basically sped up our
experimentation it made it made it
possible to be more agile with checking
different approaches and currently we
gather approximately 200 million
observations daily ok we train our model
which is an extra boost model that is
trained with a pairwise loss extra boost
has some ranking scenarios implemented
and although we started with training
with some pure
jupyter notebooks we quickly moved to a
suit of Python packages for data set
sampling for training for evaluation
that gave us like better control in the
team over what's what's going on and it
allowed us as well to you to go for
better experimentation right running
multiple jobs in parallel configuring
them keeping keeping the results and it
as well allowed us to tune hyper
parameters with with ease we which we
will see in a second we keep our results
in a tensor board as you can see on the
right and yeah let's dive into the piper
parameters a bit so this kind of model
and extra boost gradient boosting tree
model has several important parameters
that will influence the final model mod
model scores so it's an important step
to do it before going live we used a
hosted service in Google cloud platform
that is implementing the Google vision
approach and yeah and what what we found
out is that at the obvious one that
early stopping for sure is a thing that
will speed it up especially if you run
that many jobs and that actually will
for those gradient boosting mothers a
small model I mean not that many trees
as we've expected initially can perform
almost as good as a large one giving you
two until 2 nd hyper parameters even
there and we have found a few moments
that we got like bad or unexpected
results and it it came out that the
reason was some of extra boost work so
if you if you walk with it you should be
aware that that they exist ok now let's
talk about future importance once you
have for your model it's good to know
which features were actually important
which features brought some information
into the model and we've graded boosted
trees as with any complex model it's not
too easy to actually interpret your
results and with tree based models we
usually go with with metrics like cover
gain weight that's what was implemented
in XE boost the only the only problem is
that it didn't really
relate well with our industry
improvement that we got when we included
some new features into our dataset so we
went with some other methods we
investigated lime and shop right now we
are using shop and you might have heard
of it yesterday it's gonna speak about
it today as well let me shoot dr.
updated great dr. outdate yeah okay
so when working with this experiment we
were aware of a few things that are that
existed in our data and one of those was
a few biases and what my what I mean by
that is first of all position bias which
is a natural tendency for people to look
more at the top items and there are
other presentation biases for sure in
our platform for example that are that
are related to like visual markers that
some of us are highlighted promoted that
effects like is the behavior as well and
the idea in handling bias is to
understand its influence on the data and
use this knowledge to kind of debye us
the data for training and one of the
approaches basic approach presented in
one of works in the in the area is to
calculate a position based propensity
model which will reflect how likely our
people to investigate documented given
position and yeah because it assumes
that before one could actually click a
document it must first examined it and
then far find it relevant and we know
that it was both it both happened but if
if we don't ever I mean one label for
for any offer we don't know whether this
offer was not relevant for user or maybe
it was just not examined at all so we
can calculate this kind of model with
the randomization or swapping experiment
and used actually use an inverse of this
propensity score to weight your training
examples that you give more weight to
the TD more important observations and
maybe it will be more clear of discharge
so if this looks similar to the end the
CJ curve we showed at the beginning
you're right because actually this this
red dashed line is an end ECG and the
blue line is a scaled propensity that we
calculated in our experiment so you can
see they are really similar because they
capture actually it confirmed the same
the same thing that people tend to
investigate more the office on the top
and that's why this is the kind of video
weights for geometric and it can be used
as as weights for the training but in
there in an inversed
way okay now we would like to talk about
how we incorporated some high
dimensional some rich data into our
gradient boosted risk models and the
problem with greatest boosted trace is
that that they don't really work well
with rich data like images obviously and
that's the reason why why we resort to
deep learning in those cases and even
though we would love to have end-to-end
model trained fully with HDD and that
would probably solve that issue that's
just one of our future experiments that
we want to that we want to do for now we
have graded with the trees models
deployed to production but that are
actually running and we would like to
like make some use of of some of some
data like like textual data or images
into our ranking models as well so what
we decided to do is to create some
additional features based on similarity
metrics like basically something that
was covered in in the previous talk in
this home
so we basically match search phrases
with images or search phrases with
titles in document and then calculate
some some semantic semi similarity
metrics sorry like cosine or Euclidean
one and basically our objective while we
models that that calculate those
similarities is to maximize similarity
of matching and it is when it comes to
textual data the obvious choice at the
beginning was to go with words and
bearings and we which why it worked back
we tried clove it didn't provide us with
with any substantial gains mmm so we try
to look for something else now we are
using star space that's library which
was developed by Facebook AI research
and with this library we can actually
provide some some supervision into
training that's that's not purely
unsupervised approach we can provide
some some some supervision and that's in
our case implicit feedback that we are
using like the same implicit feedback
that we are using to train our learning
to rank models so we basically take some
some prayers like phrase and a title and
then try to minimize cosine distance
between positive purse and then maximize
the negative ones so you can see that on
on an image let's say that we have a
phrase like latest iPhone I have iPhone
10s and we have iPhone 6 during training
having that for that phrase someone
clicked on on the latest iPhone actually
we want to have an embedding for the
phrase latest iPhone as close to
embedding for iPhone 10s something bla
bla bla like as close as possible and
further our way than iPhone 6
okay how about images so of course the
base nine would be to take as a
representation of an image take a high
level activation from some well-known
image net
I mean mobile network trained on image
net and it was a base time for us but
since having a general image
representation would be valuable in
multiple actually domains and products
in our company like it could be visual
recommendation a visual search then we
decide
to try try to come up with a better way
to get those representations and first
of all we assigning our our own
contextual a contextual data for the
images for example make trains and Ethel
to predict some other attributes or of a
category and which which should help it
like move it to our domain and we are as
well trying again on an unsupervised
models both from the family of an
adversarial Network namely guns and from
the family of relational autoencoders
that she might have see on the second
keynote covered so and what we do of
this representation if it's not not not
clear is that we have a representation
of an image but we don't have a
representation for a phrase or for a
query within the same space so we follow
an centroid based approach so for any
any query we calculate the centroid of
all the representations of clicked or
office for for for this query and then
calculate the distance between between
those points four four four as a ranking
feature
okay now fewers on on deployment so
first of all one explanation in sites
like Allegro we actually have lots of
traffic so we have thousands of queries
per second and we have almost a hundred
million offers so that's a lot of space
to to search from and that obviously
provides some challenges and what what
we needed to apply as a thing that is
called multistage ranking so first if
you have some query let's make it read
some address it lands into our search
engine but in our case that's that solar
and in there we have some static scores
for each offer we have some static score
which is computed by some ranking model
and based on that we have some rank
documents which are not really ranked
in a contextual way but then we can just
take top-end of those documents and take
all the contextual information that we
might have I say the phrase some user
features maybe some other context which
is totally independent from from that
and apply our rear ranking model in our
ranking engine and then we get the least
of rewrite documents what so like really
important is that both the ranking model
and re-ranking model is trained using
learning to rank algorithms and that's
all based on our historical data yeah so
one like a thing that we've learned the
hard way was verification of our of our
deployment so our data our pipelines for
the online and offline has has have much
in common
but they differ a bit for example you've
learned that we use like aggregated data
as much as possible for the training but
we need to rely on on events and like
streaming data as much as possible for
the forging the production phase so
there is a bit of difference in what
data comes to the model and we need to
we need to convert both representations
to the same feature vector both when
training and when deploying and while
we're walking on like a good solution
for that that will let us solve this
problem we employ a verification
procedure that we run on on our auto
candidate and we compare basically we
compare feature distributions between
what we had in training and what we have
in our online data store and we compare
models called distributions and this
kind of we run it whenever we are the
feature or a feature change and it
happened like quite often in our in a
dynamic environment and it kind of
protects us from very each shift that
could happen with with our data set
okay so we are we are slowly coming to
the end of our slides so we would like
to share some results so we trained our
models we found like a nice improvement
way over in the offline data set and we
deployed the field models too as an a/b
test the production and we got even
better improvement so we find that it
correlates with each other so it means
good that we use we use a metric in a
way that correlates with our final
production metric and this destructed
the improvement and the production is
better than than what we had in training
great that can be justified by well the
position by us that we talked about and
as well that we were using like not a
random sample for for our training but
we used like data that was ranked parsed
by some previous version of of search
engine ranking that was that was there
before so that would be it we have time
for questions thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
thank you guys for your talk it was
brilliant
I have a small question about you you
definitely have some something like
recommender system on the side right did
you try to apply or like use the vectors
for some like data from recommendation
system in your like search algorithm for
ranking or something yeah but but I mean
you can learn like your items
representation in the recommender system
as well you know and you can try to use
this one in the search as well so I'm
just wondering if you really like
thought about this approach or maybe you
like try to use it or something well and
the kind of the recommenders that would
walk this way are currently being
developed they are not everywhere on the
platform so and I think we have tried
some time ago but this idea is really
somewhere in our our minds but not not
in baked very much
but yes I think you could be could be
thank you
and the question
thanks for the eats talk about
propensity about removing the bias so
Andy said that you did some experiments
so there were experiments where you
swapped randomly Fink's on their website
and uh I talked about an biasing the
searches so I'm curious about this step
how did you do this yeah well actually
it was it was a short experiment well we
liked the first page of the results was
not like I mean not the whole results
was was random but the order of of top
end documents was random and we could we
could calculate this this propensity
there so it happened once at some point
of the time and yeah there are methods
that do not require actually
randomization experiments and they even
try to jointly learn the the bias model
with the ranking model and but they are
like on our experimentalist because we
didn't yet managed fund to find time for
them okay
questions okay thanks thanks